Hi Bill,
so you know me as a producer at big
thing and my question for you is my
favorite question for all of our desks,
which is that keeps you up at night.
What keeps me up at night?
Climate Change,
climate change keeps me up at night.
Everywhere I looked,
there were opportunities to be
addressing climate change and everywhere
I look we're not doing it and by we I
mean not just humankind writ large,
but my United States where I grew up,
where I went to engineering school where
I worked as an engineer trying to make
the world better for somebody and we are
missing all these opportunities.
It's just crazy making and this is by
the way why I'm very proud to be the CEO
of the Planetary Society.
We are accomplishing something in space.
We are getting things done in space and
I claim that space exploration is good
for everybody.
So it's not the Apollo era.
We're not devoting 10 percent of the
world's largest government
funding to this one thing.
We're spending about point four percent
be nice if it were point five percent,
but we're spending a reasonable amount
of our intellect and treasure on
learning about the cosmos and the
Planetary Society works very hard to
direct that expenditure in what we think
is the best,
most efficient way today.
By the way,
right now is the press conference about
what instruments will be put on the
Europa mission.
This is a spacecraft going to the moon
of Jupiter called Europa.
Looking to see if it's habitable are,
is there a chance that are living things
they're such a discovery would change
the world.
With that said,
climate change keeps me up at night,
but the opportunities that we're
missing,
it's just crazy.
Making these people who are in denial of
climate change.
Look,
if you're a denial list and this will
probably find its way to you and you
will post these crazy,
mean spirited comments about me and
knock yourself out,
it's fine with that.
Brings you joy.
Okay,
but if somebody told you that there is
no connection whatsoever between smoking
and cancer,
would you vote for that person?
Would that be somebody you trust now,
50 years after that discovery was made?
Well,
the connection between humans and
climate change is about that strong and
by some very reasonable modern
statistical reckoning,
slightly stronger.
So if you're a denier out there,
I strongly encourage you to cut it out.
Just change,
just get to work.
There's nobody more passionate about the
environment than the guy who just built
his log cabin.
There's nobody who wants you to quit
smoking more strongly than the guy who
just quit.
Or the Gal who just quit.
There's no more antismoking advocate
stronger than the person who just quit
smoking.
So if you're a denier out there,
you could change and we embrace you and
we could get to work and the
opportunities are renewable energy,
transmission of electricity.
Electricity is like magical energy,
electricity,
storage or energy storage.
And then if that's from an engineering
standpoint,
and then the huge opportunity is to
create a system where people have to pay
for the carbon dioxide they create and
then take those funds that,
that treasure and redirect it into basic
research so that we can,
dare I say it,
change the world,
and then I could sleep at night.